it was advertised as a physics day but
we needed like one responsible adult to
keep us in line so he is actually a
mathematician but he's actually going to
be telling us about about biology so
you've got you've got everything all
combined here okay
thanks well I mean I don't think I'm a
responsible adult or a mathematician or
a biologist so don't take that too
seriously but you know it's Friday
afternoon it's the last session at the
workshop so you can take things a bit
high level and I'm gonna talk about some
examples of some complex biological
features and some of the ways in which
people have thought about complexity
changing over time and some and the
mechanisms by which complexity changes
over time and I think I'm going to cover
a lot of stuff that people have already
talked about but you know maybe we can
have some ideas maybe a bit of a
conversation with the audience about
some of the things that have come up
already so we think this is quite a good
summary of the way biologists are a lot
of biologists think about complexity in
life and really there's sort of two
things here so you know one is that
changes in complexity sort of occur in
qualitative steps right so you know
single celled you know single celled
animals become single celled creatures
become multicellular and you know and
then don't go back new animals evolved
animals evolved into sort of higher
groups say this form social group social
groups become more complex over time
when you know obviously there's flux
between these things but you know in
some sense the most complex thing around
has got more complex over time but of
course there's no particular reason to
think that this would happen right
there's no reason why it should be
better to be more complex no reason why
things should get more complex over time
so this is you know in some ways this is
a bit of a puzzle yeah
right oh yeah absolutely so I'm not so
I'm not making any statements about why
this would be true or not absolutely so
I mean this is the kind of like straw
man view of evolution right okay so this
is kind of silly but you start with
simple life and it becomes more complex
over time and there's a sort of
progression and then you know obviously
no one really believes this but people
still show it and slides Apes become
progressively more upright and
eventually become humans thank you right
so this is kind of you know we don't
really think this happens but of course
in some cases it does happen right so
you know it might be a good model for
things like the evolution of the
mammalian eye right so the mammalian eye
starts out as you know relatively simple
system of photoreceptors and it becomes
progressively more complex over time
through you know small additions and
small increases in complexity eventually
you end up with a very complex structure
I mean this is an example of the
evolution drug resistance in staph
aureus so this sort of circle is showing
you that the staph aureus genome and the
sort of outer five circles changes which
have happened in order to confer
resistance so you know these are these
sort of red bits on the outside of genes
which have been absorbed from other
species of bacteria and then these are
insertions I think and then the single
nucleotide changes on the inside so in
some sense you've presented this
bacteria with a complex problem that of
evading an antibiotic and it's come up
with a complex solution to it and it's
done that through a series of small
steps and and there's some kind of
there's some kind of implication here
that it's better to be more complex that
you can solve problems by becoming more
complex and finding a way around them as
of contrasting view and this is sort of
what Stephen Jay Gould called the
drunkards walk view of evolution is that
you know it's just totally random so
your lineage and you know for
generations generation you might get
more complex you might get less complex
but it's just totally around and it
doesn't have to be any pressure in one
direction or the other and say if we
plot and here complexity means whatever
you think it means if we plot complexity
and the distribution of
life you yeah I'm gonna talk a bit more
about that but for now whatever you
think it means
as long as you agrees that these things
are more or less in order of increasing
complexity okay so okay it's unfair to
the Stegosaurus not necessarily strictly
greater right but you start so you start
off with you know a bunch of stuff which
isn't very complex and and over time the
distribution just kind of spreads out
and you know because there's a barrier
at zero you know the most complex thing
you observe becomes more complex over
time eventually you get bacteria and
then life right and yeah if there's a if
there's a pressure in the in the sort of
leftward direction eventually this hits
a stationary distribution otherwise it
just keeps on spreading out forever
okay well yeah so well I mean in some
sense right
so once he says no viruses right well I
mean also even in you know I mean I said
the I was a complex structure right if
you go and live in a cave for 100
generations you'll lose your eyes say
you know yes but you know there does
seem to be something that says you know
some of these barriers are kind of
sticky right so once you get past some
level of complexity is sort of harder to
go back and and so that sort of
irreducible complexity when yeah that
here's a there are a number of ways that
can evolve but here's an example so you
start with a gene it produces this
protein and you rely on this Y shaped
domain of the protein for some function
at some point that gene gets duplicated
now you have two copies at some point
you get mutations on different parts of
each of the copies of the gene and so
but so now you know these proteins don't
fold properly but they sort of half fold
and by using the two proteins together
you can still get the same effect right
so now you've made a more complex
structure right but you can't go you
can't go back
and this is and this is called sub
functionalisation and this is a sort of
brief energy basis you mean this is a
loss of function or right right right
exactly so I mean you know lots of
things can happen after Gene duplication
right so after gene duplication
one of these can just decay and you lose
it or you know one of these can take on
a new function right so I'm not saying
this is the only thing that happens when
gene you get genes get duplicated so I'm
not saying this happens in every case
but in some cases this happens and when
it does you can't go back right and the
important thing here is that you know
none of these steps have to be adaptive
right well they don't all have to be
adaptive so you know this gene
duplication can just be neutral
you know this change can this change
this change could be neutral or
deleterious and then probably you know
if this is a recovery mutation its
adaptive but you know this doesn't this
this process can happen neutrally right
because you wrote it because that's sort
of because there's two genes involved
right two genes have to work together to
produce after two proteins have to work
together okay I mean you know okay
series more complicated than one if one
of the two you can't do anything on its
own okay
so I'm going to talk a bit about the
complexity of the genome and some
complexity of some genomic features I'm
going to talk about the human genome
first because it's the best genome and
you know how complex is the human genome
so it's already clear how to measure
this right how big is it let's start
with that
it's pretty big it's 3 billion bases but
actually that's not that big it's not
that much information you know it's
about 750 megabytes and you know there
are not many differences between our
genomes so if I want to store the genome
of the entire human species everyone on
the world you know I can probably do
that in an order of 10 petabytes right
it's not a huge amount of data CERN
generates 15 petabytes of data a year
right so yeah there's not that much
information there and and so even what
was surprisingly actually most that
information probably doesn't do anything
right so you know I apologize if this is
obvious but you know most of the human
genome is made up of transpose vil
elements right almost half of the genome
is made up of transpose by elements and
these are just sort of stretches of DNA
which have the ability to replicate
themselves and say you know they just
sort of sit there and every so often
they replicate themselves they move
around the genome right exactly so
actually only point zero five percent of
the translational elements in the human
genome are active right they they may
they make yeah they may just take up
space they may just be spaces or they'll
they may take on secondary function
right the space may be a function as
well so that I mean they make up intra
they make up most intronic sequence you
know yeah absolutely
just
like it seems like that sort of right I
mean I'm not saying I'm not saying that
is I'm just translating into another I'm
not making any comment
where's that three-dimensional structure
coming from strong exactly there's a
scene they say sequences right I mean
these are sequence as well on it I mean
look I'm not look I'm not saying that's
all the information in the genome right
I'm just I'm just I'm just putting some
numbers down I wouldn't say that but
okay that's definitely a question you
should think about so I mean that's an
open question right like what you know
what is the information content of the
genome how should we measure that how
should we count at how should we how
should we compare information content
between different genomes right and and
I I didn't have any answers for that but
okay so you know that's it and and and
there's quite quite a lot of the genome
is viral DNA as well and you know again
that might do something but you know
it's probably not fundamental and then
there's there's about 10% of the genome
that we
we really have a good idea what it does
and then then there's about a quarter of
it which is we don't know what it does
but it's not conserved across species
and it's probably not very important and
and you know I should say that you know
there are wide estimates of these
numbers and people this most yeah this
is a sort of this is a kind of
meta-analysis and they and most people
would say about ten for seven but you
know I'm not saying that's that's
definitely true yeah yeah bacteria at
bacteria are different
I mean bacteria have almost all
bacterial bacterial sequences coding
coding or immediately regulatory and
look I
okay I just I say most most bacterial
sequences okay I mean depends on the
bacteria well that's a that's a
hypothesis right I mean okay sure I mean
you know people argue this about junk
okay this is the distinction between
junk DNA and garbage DNA right se na
garbage is stuff that you throw out of
your house right junk is stuff you keep
in the garage in case it might be useful
one day that's actually quite a good
analogy for this right but but but it's
a finish a hypothesis it's not okay much
higher fraction with codeine in most
bacteria I thought it was a
yeah yeah I think I think I'm gonna
carry on here but that's okay what about
the genomes of other animals I'll say
you know genomes always varies quite a
lot
well mammalian genome is about 3 Giga
bases the smallest animal genomes we
know are about 1/10 of the size the fugu
is the smallest animal genome that
they're awesome I guess is not an animal
there are some bigger genomes their
genomes there may be an order of
magnitude bigger than the human genome
well so this is okay this is I just put
this up here this is often cited as an
example of like the biggest genome in
this amoeba and its face that has it
almost 700 gigabase DNA it's probably
this is probably a miss measurement so
I'm not sure this is actually true but
yeah these things have multiple copies
of the genome it's hard to measure okay
so you know and looking more widely
across sort of life genome size varies
by six orders of seven orders of
magnitude here you've got eukaryotes in
in green and you can see you know we the
animals that we've been looking at
they're sort of up here the prokaryotes
have smaller genomes viruses have some
water genomes okay so you saw that
genome size varies quite a lot across
animals so what about the useful
component of genome size well you know
again we don't really know how to
measure that but you know one way of
measuring it would be the number of
genes so and that's scales so on some
level you if you just look at animals
know the number of genes doesn't scale
very much with genome size and genome
size looks like more or less and
process but you know across life the
size of the genome the number of gene
scales more or less with the size of the
genome and so you know the number of
counting the number of genes might be a
reasonable way of thinking about
complexity on a on a large scale you
know and of course these genes can
interact so this is a small part of a
gene interaction network involved in
angiogenesis and pancreatic cancer and
so each of these circles is gene and
these lines say the interaction between
the genes purple lines of protein
protein interactions and the yellow and
green lines of protein DNA interactions
this is that this is the surface of the
cells that need a cell surface protein
absolutely so you know another way of
thinking about this the complexity is to
try and measure the complexity of this
network right and yeah people have sort
of tried to do that so we we know you
know we can met we can sort of measure
these networks fairly well in bacteria
it's quite hard to do in humans you know
protein protein interactions are hard to
actually measure and precent DNA
interactions are even harder to measure
so they think you know we can make a
kind of quantitative statement but you
know that's certainly one way that's
sensible to think about them and what
about other genomic features so okay
well here I'm just showing you
comparison between the sort of like for
most popular model organisms they humans
just offered us C elegans and yeast and
genome size varies a lot the number of
genes doesn't vary that much
particularly yes there are
putting humans there with 24,000 genes
than everything else would say you know
on the scale of things 24,000 genes as
is a lot of genes
there are many things with that much
than with more genes that's for you to
decide I'm gonna take no I'm gonna give
you questions you know that is a good to
say that it's a equally as good question
how might you met how might you measure
that it's one thing that does vary
enormously and that humans have a lot
more oh that are introns so you see
actually you know this is the this is
the average length of exonic sequencing
and this is the average length of
intronic sequence per gene and see
humans have an order of magnitude more
than just software or two orders of
magnitude more than C elegans so you
might think these writing introns and
and I'm sorry these n't they all say
they're so humans have more introns so
humans have an average of that's eight
introns per gene adding up to 32
kilobases so we might think that these
introns are important in complexity so
okay apologies if everyone knows this
but you know what are introns do well
okay so this is the cartoon of a gene
and gene is made up of sort of bits of
exonic sequences bye-bye introns and
ribosomes can scribes this into RNA
transcribes the introns as well and then
cellular machinery called the
spliceosome comes along and sits on the
RNA and spices out all the introns rate
and joins the exons together in the
right order and then this gets
translated and folds into into a protein
okay so you okay this blank space here
implies there something else and in fact
there is so actually many genes and I'll
come to how many in a minute can be
alternatively spliced so sometimes the
the exons can be shuffled in different
orders and that gives you a different
protein product have a completely
different function okay so in humans
okay again this is hard this is hard to
measure right so wait so in it say we
measure this by sequencing RNA from
cells and when you do that if you seek
enough RNA you start to find that pretty
much every possible transcript is
represented question of how many of them
actually make protein products is as is
on is kind of unknown but at least half
of all human genes have no alternative
transcripts which are expressed it
pretty high levels and they tend to be
expressed in different tissues and at
different developmental stages so we're
going to show you an example here so
this is the human gene and you're
reading along the sequence from left to
right here and these each line is a
different transcript to this gene so the
the sort of solid bits here are the
exons and the - bits along here are the
introns right and this is sort of
typical that you know small exonic
regions separated by by long end Rondon
and this gene has a large number of
alternative transcripts not all of these
actually make crazy product but actually
in this particular case the you know
these longer transcripts are expressed
in the adult brain and the shorter
transcripts are expressed in the fetal
heart right so this gene probably does
different things at different stages of
development but you know a lot of these
transcripts don't actually make protein
products so they're just kind of noise
and actually this trans transcripts at
the top are fusion transcripts of two
genes of this gene another gene which is
the upstream yeah
which has a stop codon yeah yeah so you
know sure or these may all have these
are all these these transcripts will
exist in the cell at the same time and
it's hard to say that they don't
actually do anything not saying that
some of them really are expressed at
very low levels and also you know many
of these transcripts actually just get
broken down some of them by nonsense
mediator K C sayings and there are other
pathways which break down some of these
transcripts so you might say you know
this sort of natural explanation for
this is that okay you've got another
limited number of genes and you want to
become more complex you want to express
these genes in more combinations so you
know maybe you start shuffling the genes
around and then you can express them at
different times and get more complexity
this is actually a good argument so I'm
gonna just present an argument that says
no so okay first of all there's quite a
large cost to having big introns and
lots of splicing right so you know you
have to transcribe all the introns
that's there's a cost to do that okay
you have to make a splices ohm and
there's a cost to do that yeah
alternative splicing is very noisy
process they say you know so much so
that there are specific pathways which
break down transcripts which have been
which have been Mis spliced and you know
perhaps even more convincing actually
you know mutations in splice sites you
know really have fitness effects right
so I mean estimates vary but somewhere
between a third and a half of all human
genetic diseases are caused by mutations
in splice sites right so you know just
say it says but yeah it's pretty big
cost and so what I'm showing you here
and this is an argument by Michael Lynch
is a plot across different species so
each dose is a different species and
this shows you okay you think of this as
a proxy for population size from the x
axis and on the y axis and the solid
dots is an average number of introns per
gene and the open dots are the average
length of the
purging right species with larger
population sizes have fewer introns and
smaller introns right now if it was
adaptive to have lots of introns you
would expect this relationship to be the
other way around right
remember selection acts more efficiently
when population size is large okay so
this would be a sort of model where
introns are right so oh I should have
said probably earlier so you know
introns have been around for a long time
so in introns were probably presence in
the original you carriers but introns
this is a model where introns kind of
spread as a selfish DNA elements in his
neutral way and then later get co-opted
new orders to get alternative splicing
and more complexity right but the
initial step need not be adaptive okay
silence okay so I said that you know
this is this is controversial right I
mean this is not yeah not everyone it's
not everyone would accept this but you
know I think it's certainly and it's a
null hypothesis right I think you need
to disprove this before you start
talking about the adaptability
okay so I mean change tack a bit and
rather than talking about the complexity
of the genome I'm going to start talking
about the complexity of the organism
itself and okay so it's back to the
Quaker to stop you know Maynard Smith
and Mari defined these major transitions
in the history of life right and they
define them as major changes in the way
in which information is stored and
transmitted between generations
right so that qualitative changes and I
mean okay so number eight is a bit silly
and and one two three is sort of a bit
lost in the mists of time but I'm gonna
say a little bit about about the middle
four and you know I think pretty much
all of these has been touched on over
time so this would be a good point for
people to step in and say what they say
what they think say okay yeah we've
heard a lot about prokaryotes and
eukaryotes I'm just gonna point out this
cartoon of the differences between them
they're pretty hairy it's a small they
have a cell wall there
ocular chromosomes eukaryotes so
eukaryotic cells much bigger linear
chromosomes really keeping the separate
nucleus they have a sonic 2 skeleton
which means they can change shape and be
larger we showed on here but they sort
of compartmentalize different cellular
processes insert into different
compartments in and perhaps most
importantly they have mitochondria right
and mitochondria as there are little
organelles which generate ATP which is a
chemical used by other cellular
processes in order to do so they
basically produce they basically allow
it they basically produce its mechanism
that allows other cellular processes to
use the energy of the cell creates ok we
as we mentioned this yesterday bit look
like the transcriptional regulation
machinery is very different in
mitochondria yeah oh yeah I mean okay
this is not all the differences but you
know these are sort of the major um and
you know we actually MIT so the
evolution of mitochondria is sort of
like that is the classic like crazy idea
that turned out to be right and it turns
out the mitochondria are actually the
result of symbiosis between two ancient
species of bacteria so here's some
Kartini let's see down here we have kind
of a pre eukaryotic life and there's a
cuts of complex reticulated phylogeny
down here and the ancestor of all
eukaryotes in which is here on this
purple lineage at some point probably
lost that cell wall and then the
ancestor and then absorbs the ancestor
of mitochondria into the cell and then
at some point some of the mitochondrial
genes were transferred to the nucleus of
the eukaryotic cell we'll come back to
that in a minute and then you know this
fact and then this other bacteria which
had evolved photosynthesis was absorbed
into one of these repair eásá clean
edges and became plants and this this
actually happens several times so algae
are a separate lineage on which this
happened but he you get mitochondrial
probably only evolved once so this was a
single event and it's fairly easy to see
how this could evolve as
you know symbiotic relationship which is
beneficial to both of the participants
right so nice quandary lives inside the
cell it gets to have a good place to
live and divide but we get some
protection the cell gets something that
it can use it I mean it's what happens
in this initial stage is hard to you
know we have really no idea about yeah I
think we have no idea why this was
initially beneficial for the cell but
it's not hard to imagine why would
statement I'm I don't know which points
on this tree the cytoskeleton and the
nucleus evolved presumably I mean it's
like it so it's likely that this I mean
the cell wall was probably lost before
the mitochondria was engulfed because
otherwise you can engulf but you know
the other other impre-- any other
aspects I don't think we really know
about yeah I don't know does anyone know
how okay I get their energy you say you
say why why archaea don't have
mitochondria right maybe not right I
mean I you know I yeah I I mean I can't
speak for the for the origin of the
archaea right I don't know if anyone
here lost somewhere up here maybe who
knows this was presumably presumably you
know I don't think we know how how old
this relationship is right suma bleah I
mean I I wouldn't I wouldn't say okay
yeah so they're a bunch of changes at
this point on the lives okay so let me
let me let me generalize that statement
and just say there's a bunch of changes
on all of these lineages everywhere
right so you know any statement you want
to make it can be okay okay
so okay we've heard a lot about the
evolution of sex say but I just want to
make it clear that you know there are
lots of things associated with sex which
you know which are also complex and
which have also evolved but on you know
necessarily the same say you know
recombination you know sex and
recombination are not the same thing it
seems to happen a lot of the time but
you know you have recombination without
sex you can have sex without
recombination so yeah the evolution of
recombination is in some ways a separate
but related problem the e-value
of sexes is again a separate but related
problem right you don't need to have you
know separate male or female organisms
in order to have sex the evolution of
obligate sex is another problem right so
okay let me go to see so this is just
concentrating on animals right but there
are asexual animals they tend on
evolutionary scales you know they tend
to go extinct is quite quickly right
there are many asexual animals that look
like they have been around for a long
time so it sort of seems like it's
possible to to lose sex but then you go
extinct quickly the only possible
exception these guys at the delaware
rotifers a little microscopic animals
and they it's claimed that they have
been asexual for something on the order
of 80 million years they have very weird
genomes so you know it's possible it's
possible that's true or it's possible
that they're we wear genomes are
obscuring the fact that they're having
sex but but generally you know
everything else is everything everything
else is are those asexual is young you
know a lot of animals a facultative say
that they you know they have sex some at
the time but not all of the time and
they sort of rage so you know the bat
tip sharks you know they can you know
they have sex almost all the time but
when conditions are very bad they can
basically clean themselves female sharks
can claim themselves Daphnia they tend
to be asexual when conditions are good
and then be sexual when conditions about
add maybe that helps them to you to
adapt some lineages of daphne are a
social and c elegans you notice I think
as Boris mentioned you C elegans is most
of the time its elfing but there are
occasionally occasional males the C
elegans aren't male or female they're
either hermaphrodites or males they but
generally males are quite rare and apnea
don't have sex chromosomes actually so
Dead Sea Daphne I don't have male or
females and then you know some animals
are obligate sexual so they have to they
have to have sex in order to reproduce
and if you think about it you know this
is quite strange thing to evolve right
you know you're giving up the option to
clone yourself
hard to it's hard to imagine what I
started to imagine why you would give
that up and in some of these say in
mammals for example actually mammals
have imprinted genes so you know you've
got one copy of your genome for your
mother and one from your father for some
of your genes you'll only express the
copy you got from your mother and from
some of your genes your Leone Express
the copy got in your father right and
that's sort of a barrier to cloning
yourself because if you clone your if
you clone yourself you female you clone
yourself then you know that your
daughter will not have a paternal copy
of these imprinted genes when express it
right see that's something that sort of
prism prevents mammals becoming asexual
but it's sort of hard to think about how
and it's still hard to imagine how that
might evolve what's the benefit of
obligate sexuality right so you know
okay yeah we know there's a lot on the
other side I was just increasing
frequency of sex that's all right yeah
so you know zero and one and some
something in the middle okay so okay
there are lots of explanations for sex
and we've heard a lot of them I'm not
going to go into them I sort of you know
there there are a lot of things which
suggest some benefit there's you know
mother's ratchet which removes
deleterious alleles and there are sort
of like explanations that are that are
basically neutral and yeah
you mean think things that have been
sexual that become asexual yes so also
all those examples I showed which which
are asexual are have lost sex yeah yeah
they were sexual and they've lost sense
and and yeah I mean it's common in
before it's relatively common in phones
as well plant or what most plants are
faculties is so yeah yeah because when
they become asexual you know they become
extinct very quickly so you know there
are all specs nations for for sex and
why it's why it's good I mean a lot of
these explanations it's very it's are
easy to explain on the group level but
hard to explain to the individual right
so you know mother's ratchet removes
tell serious variation yeah it's good
for the population right you've come
yeah your species doesn't go extinct but
it's not so good for you but you know
sex is not so good to necessarily say
good for the individual right so you you
know I think thinking about how we're
explained sex we need to actually
separate out some of these explanations
into you and you know and didn't I cook
of course these explanations are not
exclusive right so there are lots of
benefits we say lots of disadvantages
but it's possible that the benefits
which are selected on to start having
sex different from the benefits which
maintain it different from the
advantages which cause you to become
obligate sexual rather than faculty to
say yeah there's probably no one overall
explanation okay
multicellularity okay this is again you
know this is an aggregation of smaller
units into larger more complex units and
there again there's a sort of hierarchy
from single cells to colonies and really
the sort of key step in in
multicellularity specialization where
some cells actually specialize and give
up the ability to reproduce right so you
know in some ways they become altruistic
towards
the rest of the organism and so you know
it's relatively easy to get single cells
to aggregate into colonies by bacterial
biofilms a common example and we heard
on in Oscars talk this morning there you
know it's relatively easy in
experimental evolution settings to get
yeast to grow into clumps and things
like that it seems to be a bit harder to
actually grow you know truly
multicellular organisms and this algae
is the kind of model for the very early
evolution of multicellularity so it so
these are sort of spheres and the cells
on the outside a specialized for
swimming and eating and then some of the
cells on the inside a specialized for
reproduction and the cells on the
outside can no longer reproduce
independently and so that seems to be
slightly harder to obtain although you
know it's easy enough that it's happened
many times so it probably happens at
least 25 times this is the Tree of Life
and this is just okay well you know you
read shows you multicellularity and
black cells it shows you Eunice Ellie
entirety and it's it's you know it's
evolved on all of these lineages
separately okay but again you know
explanation says you know it's easy to
see how it's good for the organism as a
whole but it's not necessarily easy to
see how it's good for the individual
right why is it good for the cell to be
part of a larger organism if it's not
going to reproduce right yeah so okay
and I'm just you know just [ __ ] just
just fine just finally um you know
social behavior okay you know this is
like cells coming together to make an
organism this is individuals coming
together to make a society and behaving
altruistically and and in many ways it's
sort of requires the same explanation
okay this is these are bees who have
died in the process of killing this wasp
which has attacked their high of rates a
bit you know
the bees have sacrificed themselves for
the good of the hive okay but it doesn't
matter because they're female workers
and they don't really produce anyway so
it's hard yeah it's hard yeah again yeah
it's hard to see how that that how that
would have gone so like some classical
explanation and probably I think the one
that most biologists
today we still believe is something
along the lines of kin selection and
this basically says you know if I am
closely related to you then I it's good
for me to do something to help you
because that helps your genes which are
the same as mine right now sort of
summed up by hit by Hamilton's rule and
so here C is is the cost to me B is the
benefit to you and R is on relatedness
right so if I'm closely related to you
I'll do something at a cost to me that
benefits you and really the devil here
is in what R is okay so it's some
measure of how closely we are related
and depending on how exactly you define
it you can get quite different behaviors
from this rule but this is the sort of
absolutely yeah yeah so absolutely I
mean so if you see look at say your body
all the cells in your body are more or
less the same genotype and so you know
it's not a hot thing it's sort of easy
to invoke this argument on the other
hand you know it happens quite commonly
that cells in your body decide to go
crazy and just try and replicate
themselves at the expense of your body
you know in fact it's so common that it
you know if you wait long enough it will
be it will happen to everyone
so you know any explanation has to take
that into account right that you know
there's a strong pressure there's a
strong pressure to break out from this
yeah sorry yeah
okay so you know it's sort of often
often set up as an alternative to kin
selection is group selection multi-level
section and this basically invokes
selection on different levels they say
you know they're selecting on the level
of the individual but they angry Gator
to form a group their selection on the
level of the group you know which
preserves traits in the individual right
now
you know it's relatively easy to model
this it's sort of harder to find kind of
real mechanistic explanations right and
you know and this is this is fairly
controversial among biologists I think
so right right right sorry yeah so
exactly so he's gonna say this this is a
recent and extremely controversial paper
advocating a model of grief selection
and you know yeah who didn't understand
so hot I'd say you'd say half the world
says that they know a canal day and
understand what's going on and half and
naraka all say the rest of I think it's
well I I think I think it's worth
reading this paper although I you know
you really you have to read the
supplementary information because the
the paper itself doesn't have it just
because I want to be topical any current
I mean there's you know there's an older
literature on group selection and
there's an older literature bashing
group selection and you know this debate
has been going on for you know I don't
know the best part of the century right
right very good point
okay so the question was could it be
this debate is asking questions which
are not easily falsifiable and I think
that's been a real problem you know
because it's very hard to test for this
in nature right I mean there are lot of
these very experiments do this but you
know there's nothing really convincing I
think and that and that's kind of that's
kind of the reach of the problem so if
we what you know really what we need to
think about if you know if you want to
understand which models are useful we
need to be designing experiments they
can actually test them use a multi-level
selection are you applying right so you
can think selection implies a certain
level of group selection right sure but
you know something but there there can
be additional term selection I mean they
complain you know they can based be yeah
I mean you know these groups are likely
so they likely to be related or not yes
or you know additional so you know your
social group is likely to be related to
you and that and so kids will actually
apply some level of group selection but
if there's additional if there's an
additional term on top of that implies
make it so you know these things are not
exclusive okay
I mean you know what else so okay so I
talked I talked about and I talked about
cancer and you know the reason you don't
get cancer all the time is because you
have you know complex mechanism which
which says that when cells start to
divide out of control they kill
themselves right breakstep stop chanson
and you know there are at all levels
there are two control mechanisms which
evolved to keep keep the system in place
of course you know this is really just
pushing the problem elsewhere right
because these control mechanisms after
evolved in the first place right so you
know imprinting makes animals be
obligate sexual but how did that evolve
in the first place that's just pushing
the question elsewhere and the last
thing I want to emphasize is you know
you don't necessarily have to look for
selection right yeah we don't we're
arguing about what kind of selection is
important but yeah actually maybe
there's just no selection okay remember
you know weakly deleterious alleles
still have quite
big chance to fix in a small population
and the population size of humans is
quite small so the long-term effects of
population size of humans is is may be
10 to the 4 and this is a plot showing
you estimates of population size over
time so this is the present you're going
back in time in years
and and the y-axis shows you the effects
of population size and one is 10 to the
10 to the 4 so and the different lines
show you different colored populations
right and so for some populations
particularly for for Europeans here you
know sometimes in parts the population
size has been very low so this is that
this is the Out of Africa but on that
population side you know the effective
population size is like a hundred okay
so you know and humans are probably not
unique in species and having gone
through regular large bottlenecks so
perhaps we shouldn't be surprised if a
lot of the variation we see is actually
just not selective at all we're just
living in the wrong place so you know
this is the model where you know you're
at it you're at a fitness peak and you
can fall down by drift and then maybe
you climb up somewhere else in the first
plot so this is is time in the past
right so the the the origin is the
present no the origin is 10,000 years
ago and and you're going back in time on
a log scale and the y-axis is the
effective population size of humans so
something which we think is proportional
to the population size and okay so okay
in some what in some okay so in some
models the effects population size is
proportional to the population size
right but the point is for this for this
argument you know what it was important
is the effective population size right
so the the definition that says
deleterious alleles will fix with this
probability is the same as the
definition which gives you this plot so
the you know what's importance is is
this plot not the Census Bureau's
one over two and the real population
says it's in one copy if any tells you
like the Selective coefficient below
which it's neutral that's okay that's
true okay so any set any tells it any
tells you how strongly selection same
allowed but you know these population
sizes really are very small does okay so
I just I just want to finish by saying
what as I said before you know I think
we've got lots of models right we've
seen lots of models everyone's talked
about different models and they're all
good models but you know and they're
probably all valid you know in some
parameter regime you know for some
species in some place and time and the
question is you know really what's the
relative importance of all these
different models and what predictions do
they make them we can actually go out
and test you know in nature and I think
I think maybe Daniels going to go into
the complexities of some of these models
a bit more but that's really all I've
got to say